bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
d'un argument climatceptique qu'on
entend assez régulièrement l'effet de
serre serait saturé c'est-à-dire que
supposément l'effet de serre serait déjà
à son maximum et donc on pourrait bien
ajouter autant de CO2 qu'on veut dans
l'atmosphère ça ne provoquerait pas plus
de réchauffement qu'il n'y en a déjà
actuellement cet argument il est
intéressant parce qu'on va voir qu'il
repose sur un raisonnement physique
assez convaincant l'argument n'est pas
correct évidemment mais pour voir
pourquoi il va falloir comprendre
comment fonctionne vraiment l'effet de
serre dans l'atmosphère soyons clair he
mon but avec cette vidéo n'est pas de
convaincre les climatceptiques ils ont
décidé de ne pas croire les milliers de
scientifiques qui travaillent déjà sur
la question je vois pas pourquoi il me
croiraient moi non l'idée c'est de
m'adresser à vous et d'utiliser ce
prétexte pour parler de phénomène
physiquees intéressant et important et
on va découvrir que ce mécanisme de
l'effet de serre porte plutôt mal son
nom et est en fait assez différent de ce
qu'on imagine au premier abord quand on
fait la comparaison avec une serre et
j'avoue que moi-même j'avais pas
vraiment tout compris au
début commençons avec le soleil c'est
lui qui fournit à la terre l'immense
majorité de son énergie et il le fait au
moyen du rayonnement vous savez
peut-être qu'il y a principalement trois
modes de transmission de la chaleur la
conduction qui fonctionne par contact la
convection quand on a un fluide dont les
mouvements transportent la chaleur et
enfin le rayonnement
électromagnétique entre le Soleil et la
Terre il y a l'Espace he qui est
essentiellement vide donc il n'y a que
le rayonnement vous savez peut-être que
le soleil émet sa lumière dans une
certaine plage de longueur d'onde et
qu'on peut tracer une courbe qui montre
l'intensité du rayonnement émis en
fonction des longueur d'onde c'est ce
qu'on appelle le spectre du soleil au
centre ici on a la lumière visible hein
entre 0,4 et 0,8 microns de longueur
d'onde avant les ultraviolets avec des
longueurs d'ondes plus courtes et après
les infrarouges la forme de cette courbe
elle ne vient pas de nulle part elle
suit une loi physique universelle qu'on
appelle la loi de planque et qui ne
dépend que de la température de surface
pour le soleil c'est environ 5800 Kin
soit un peu plus de 6000° celus mais si
le soleil était un peu plus froid ou un
peu plus chaud disons plus ou moins 200°
la courbe serait légèrement
différente bien ce spectre représente
donc l'intensité du rayonnement du
soleil pour chaque longueur d'onde
maintenant si on veut connaître
l'ensemble de la puissance lumineuse que
le soleil rayonne et bien il faut
additionner tout ça mathématiquement ça
revient à regarder l'air totale sous la
courbe bon pour les intimes ça s'appelle
faire une intégrale et ici dans le cas
du soleil on trouve une puissance
cumulée d'environ 63 MW par M car ça
veut dire qu'un panneau d'un m car placé
pile à la surface du Soleil recevrait
environ 63 MW de puissance rayonnée
évidemment la terre est heureusement
située assez loin du soleil et nous on
reçoit beaucoup moins que ça si on ne
compte pas le rayonnement qui est
directement réfléchi par la surface ou
les nuages la terre absorbe 240 W de
rayonnement solaire par mètre carré bien
sûr c'est une valeur moyenne hein ça
dépend évidemment du moment de la
latitude et cetera mais retenez bien ce
chiffre 240 W par mè carré c'est le flux
d'énergie en provenance du Soleil que la
Terre absorbe sur l'ensemble des
longueurs d'ondes du spectre et c'est
comme ça que le soleil chauffe la terre
sauf que si n'y avait que ça juste
l'apport de chaleur en provenance du
soleil et bien la terre accumulerait de
l'énergie se réchaufferait en permanence
et indéfiniment et ça fait longtemps
qu'elle aurait fondu heureusement la
terre a un moyen d'évacuer la chaleur en
retour et c'est également via du
rayonnement la terre est met aussi en
permanence un rayonnement
électromagnétique vers l'espace et comme
pour le soleil ce rayonnement a un
certain spectre et c'est ce spectre qui
va nous intéresser car c'est lui qui va
gouverner la façon dont la terre évacue
l'énergie et là ce qui est important
c'est vraiment ce qui est émis vers
l'espace on sait qu'on a la terre
l'atmosphère qui va se passer des trucs
là-dedans avec le rayonnement mais nous
tout ce qui nous intéresse à la fin
c'est ce qui sort au sommet de
l'atmosphère imaginez qu'on se place
au-dessus avec un satellite et qu'on
mesure tout le rayonnement qui s'échappe
en moyenne de la terre voilà c'est ça
qu'on veut être capable de quantifier
pour comprendre comment la Terre évacue
l'énergie alors comment on estime ce
spectre de rayonnement vu depuis
l'espace pour commencer doucement on va
faire un truc simple et un peu bizarre
on va d'abord supposer qu'il n'y a pas
d'effet de serre on va garder toutes les
autres caractéristiques de la terre he
l'océan les nuages et cetera mais on va
juste mentalement éteindre l'effet de
serre s'il n'y a pas d'effet de serre le
rayonnement que la terre évacue vers
l'espace est exactement celui qu'elle
l'émet depuis sa surface le rayonnement
traverse l'atmosphère sans être affecté
donc pour savoir ce qui s'échappe il
nous suffit de connaître le spectre du
rayonnement émis par la surface de la
Terre et là c'est plutôt simple hein la
surface de la Terre est comme la surface
du Soleil elle émet un rayonnement de
planque qui est lié à sa température
voici à quoi il ressemble à première V
la forme du spectre semble très
similaire à ce qu'on avait pour le
soleil mais il y a une première grosse
différence ce sont les longueurs d'onde
regardez ici j'ai gradué jusqu'à 50
microns sur l'axe des abscisses et
l'essentiel de l'émission se fait entre
disons 5 et 30 pour le soleil le gros de
l'émission se faisait en dessous de 2
microns et notamment dans la partie
visible qui est entre 0,4 et 0,8 je vous
la remets pour
visualiser si c'est si différent c'est
parce que la température de surface de
la Terre est bien plus basse que celle
du soleil et donc la terre émet du
rayonnement dans ce qu'on appelle les
infrarouges lointains si je trace le
spectre du soleil avec le même axe des
abscisses on voit que les longueurs
d'ondes du rayonnement de la terre et du
soleil sont presque complètement
séparées l'autre différence entre la
surface de la Terre et celle du soleil
du fait de leur énorme différence de
température c'est que l'intensité total
du rayonnement est beaucoup plus faible
vous vous souvenez on l'obtenait en
sommant toutes les longueurs d'
c'est-à-dire en calculant l'air sous la
courbe pour le soleil ça faisait 63 MW
par mè Carr pour la terre ça va faire
beaucoup moins et encore heureux hein la
terre n'est pas une étoile alors ça a
pas l'air comme ça sur mes deux courbes
car j'ai utilisé des échelles très
différentes en ordonnées mais en
cumulant l'énergie totale émise par la
surface de la Terre on va plutôt être
entre 200 et 400 W par mètre Carr je
reste volontairement assez vague sur la
fourchette car on va justement devoir
préciser ça on l'a dit la terre absorbe
240 W par mè car en provenant du soleil
et pour faire le bilan ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir exactement en
contrepartie combien elle rerayonne vers
l'espace la forme précise du spectre de
la terre dépend de la température
moyenne de sa surface je vous met
plusieurs de ces spectres pour des
températures entre - 40 et + 40° celus
on voit que plus la température est
élevée plus la surface sous la courbe
est grande et donc la puissance totale
rayonnée est importante et comme c'est
pas très simple de comparer visuellement
ces surfaces ici je vous mets le total
de puissance correspondant pour chacune
de ces courbes on voit que suivant la
température de surface bah ça se balade
entre 150 et plus de 500 W par mè Carr
il faut bien comprendre que ces
différentes valeurs de puissance totale
correspondent aux différentes aires des
surfaces sous les courbes si je me
concentre par exemple sur les spectres
pour 0 et 5° celus elles correspondent
respectivement à 315 et 339 W ça ça fait
24 W de différence et ces 24 W sont
vraiment la surface de la petite bande
entre les deux spectres que j'ai coloré
en jaune cette idée de comparer des
surfaces sous les spectres et d'en
déduire des différences de puissance
rayonné on va la retrouver tout le long
de nos explications voilà on sait
quantifier l'énergie perdue par la terre
en fonction de la température de sa
surface dans l'hypothèse où l'effet de
serre a magiquement disparu maintenant
on a dit que le soleil nous fournissait
200 140 W par mè Carr en moyenne si on
veut que la terre soit à l'équilibre
qu'elle reçoive autant d'énergie qu'elle
en émet et bien il faut qu'elle rayonne
aussi en retour 240 W par M car et on
peut voir sur la courbe que ça
correspondrait à une température de
surface d'environ -1° celus - 18° ce
serait la température corrélataire à
l'équilibre si on éteignait juste les
faet de ser mais en gardant tout le
reste et les 240 W correspondants c'est
l'air sous la courbe du spectre de plan
plan qu'on obtient à
-18° sans effet de serre la terre serait
à l'équilibre thermique à -1° et surtout
le truc se régulerait tout seul si la
terre était par exemple plus froide
disons - 25° le total rayonné serait
seulement de 215 W par mè²r moins que ce
qu'elle reçoit du soleil donc il y
aurait 25 W par mè Carr de déséquilibre
ce déséquilibre c'est ce qu'on appelle
le forçage radiatif le bonus de
puissance qu'on reçoit du fait de ne pas
être à la température d'équilibre
du fait de ces 25 W par mèt carré de
forçage radiatif la terre se
réchaufferait et sa température
augmenterait jusqu'à atteindre
l'équilibre à - 18°gr à l'inverse si la
terre était plus chaude que cet
équilibre elle rayonnerait plus que 240
W par mèt Carr elle perdrait donc de
l'énergie se refroidirait et tendrait
aussi vers -1°r bien je vous rappelle
que tout ça c'était sans effet de serre
he dans le cas où le rayonnement émis à
la surface traverse complètement
l'atmosphère et s'échappe dans les
espace maintenant on va rallumer l'effet
de serre alors pour des raisons que je
vais vous expliquer dans la suite on va
voir que l'impact de l'effet de serre et
de diminuer la capacité de la terre à
évacuer de l'énergie à cause de l'effet
de serre la courbe en rouge est remplacé
par quelque chose qui ressemble à la
courbe en vert à température équivalente
l'énergie s'évacue moins bien notamment
on voit maintenant que pour évacuer 240
W par mè carré la terre doit avoir une
température de surface de 288 Kelvin
environ 15°r celus en rallumant l'effet
de serre on a diminué la capacité de la
terre à évacuer la chaleur et donc on a
déplacé le point d'équilibre de plus de
30°r et c'est une bonne manière de se
représenter ce que fait l'effet de serre
une perte de capacité d'évacuation
d'énergie et donc un déplacement de
l'équilibre vers des températures plus
chaudes et donc l'effet de serre c'est
puissant et c'est indispensable à une
bonne partie de la vie telle qu'on la
connaît puisque c'est ce qui permet
qu'il fasse en moyenne 15°grés sur terre
plutôt que - 18 bien notre but dans la
suite ça va donc être de comprendre le
mécanisme détaillé qui provoque cette
moins bonne évacuation de la chaleur par
la terre mais avant ça revenons sur
l'appellation effet de serre c'est une
analogie assez ancienne qu'on doit
d'ailleurs au scientifique français
Joseph Fourier au 19e siècle imaginez
une serre dont j'aurais retiré toutes
les vitres il reste plus que le cadre
métallique ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
reçoit la chaleur du soleil par
rayonnement et en retour cette chaleur
sera perdue notamment par les mouvements
de l'air he puisque j'ai viré les vitres
maintenant si je remets les vitres je
limite la capacité de la serre à évacuer
sa chaleur il ne reste plus qu'un peu de
conduction et de rayonnement je crée
donc un déséquilibre qui fait augmenter
la température et vous voyez que c'est
surtout une histoire de supprimer la
convection pas vraiment de rayonnement
comme dans leseffit de serre
atmosphérique donc retenez que
l'analogie a ses limites bien alors
revenons juste justement à la terre
pourquoi est-ce que les gaz à effet de
serre causent ce qu'on appelle l'effet
de serre et bien vous le savez peut-être
c'est parce qu'ils absorbent les
rayonnements infrarouges ou du moins
certaines longueurs d'onde dans les
infrarouges et pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
absorbent et bien parce que ça les
excite alors oui oui c'est vraiment
comme ça qu'on dit les molécules comme
le CO2 ou la vapeur d'eau sont
susceptibles d'absorber certains
rayonnements infrarouge qui
correspondent à l'énergie nécessaire
pour les mettre dans des états dit
excités dans ces états les molécules ont
des mouvements qui sont des sortes de
torsions ou d'élongation de leur
structure et ce sont des mouvements qui
n'existent pas pour des molécules comme
le dioxygène ou le diazote qui ne sont
donc pas des gaz à effet de serre alors
que le méthane le CO2 la vapeur d'eau ou
le protoxyde d'azote en sont
l'absorption de rayonnement infrarouge
se fait pour chaque molécule dans des
plages de longueur d'onde qui
correspondent aux énergies qui les
mettent dans ses états excités on
appelle ça les bandes d'absorption et
c'est pour pour ça que les gaz à effet
de serre absorbent certains rayonnements
mais en laisse passer d'autres là où
c'est pas de bol c'est qu'il n'absorbe
pas beaucoup les rayonnements visibles
he ceux que nous envoie le soleil mais
ils absorbent pas mal dans les longueurs
d'onde des infrarouges émis par la Terre
il laisse passer la chaleur entrante
mais pas la chaleur sortante et c'est ce
qui va limiter la capacité de la terre à
évacuer son énergie comme la Terre
reçoit en moyenne 240 W par mètre carré
de la part du soleil on l'a dit pour
être à l'équilibre elle doit évacuer
aussi 240 W par mè Carr mais du coup
est-ce que c'est le cas pour bien
l'analyser en présence d'effet de serre
il faut bien faire cette fois la
distinction entre le spectre émis à la
surface de la Terre et celui qu'on
verrait avec un satellite depuis le
sommet de l'atmosphère c'est lui qui
nous intéresse hein car c'est celui-là
qui nous dit ce que la terre arrive à
évacuer vers l'espace distingons donc
bien les deux spectres celui est mis par
la surface de la Terre et ce qui
s'échappe au sommet de l'atmosphère
qu'on peut mesurer en principe avec un
satellite
sans effet de serre le spectre émis par
la surface est exactement celui qui sort
au sommet de l'atmosphère donc s'il y a
un total de 240 W par mètre carré est
mis à la surface ce sera le même qui
s'évacue c'est
l'équilibre maintenant si on rallume
soudainement lesffit de serre et si les
gaz à effet de serre empêche la sortie
du rayonnement dans certaines bandes
infrarougge ça va créer comme un trou
dans le spectre émis vers l'espace et
qui dit trou dans le spectre dit une air
sous la courbe plus faible donc moins
d'énergie
moins en tout cas que les 240 W qu'on
reçoit du soleil ça crée donc un
déséquilibre qui réchauffe la
terre la température de surface va alors
augmenter le spectre émis à la surface
va légèrement enfler jusqu'à ce que le
total de ce qui sort atteigne à nouveau
les 240 W par mètre carré nécessaires et
que l'équilibre soit
retrouvé avec cette visualisation comme
un trou dans le spectre on comprend le
mécanisme les gaz à effet de serre
bloquent une partie du rayonnement
sortant la terre évacue moins bien sa
chaleur et donc se réchauffe pour
retrouver l'équilibre c'est limpide non
sauf que vous voyez que ça a une limite
si dans une certaine bande de longueur
d'onde tout est absorbé le trou serait
maximal et dans ce cas ça ne pourrait
plus empirer et ben on dirait bien que
c'est ce qui se passe avec le CO2
regardons de plus près ces bandes
d'absorption vous les voyez schématisé
ici ça représente en gros l'intensité de
l'absorption du CO2 en fonction de la
longueur d'onde pour une pression une
température donnée la principale bande
est autour de 15
microns maintenant si on prend le
rayonnement émis par la surface de la
terre autour de ces longueurs d'onde on
peut se demander quelle fraction de ce
rayonnement est actuellement absorbé par
le CO2 présent dans l'atmosphère et la
réponse est 100 %. et non seulement
c'est 100 % mais c'est assez violent he
c'est même totalement absorbé dans les
premières dizaines de mètres si vous
preniez un laser mé puissant qui tire
dans l'infrarouge autour de 15 microns
le rayon n'irait pas bien haut avant
d'être complètement absorbé par
l'atmosphère l'atmosphère de la terre
absorbe déjà à mort dans les bandes
d'absorption du CO2 donc on peut bien
doubler ou tripler la concentration de
CO2 dans l'atmosphère il ne va pas
absorber plus que ce qu'il absorbe déjà
vu qu'il absorbe déjà tout pour prendre
une image hein si vous avez une vitre
complètement noire épaisse de 5 cm qui
ne laisse pas passer la lumière vous
pouvez bien la faire de 10 ou 20 cm
d'épaisseur ça changera rienin l'impact
du CO2 sur l'effet de serre c'est pareil
il est saturé il ne pourra pas être plus
fort que ce qu'il n'est et donc il n'y a
pas de problème de réchauffement
climatique à moins
que c'est quand même bizarre parce que
l'argument a l'air assez convaincant et
en même temps les scientifiques du
climat qui savent quand même de quoi il
parlent nous disent que si par exemple
on double la concentration de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère on va créer un déséquilibre
un forçage radiatif d'au moins 3 boîtes
par mètre carré provoquant un
réchauffement de quelques degrés ils
sont bêtes les climatologues ils ont pas
vu que c'était saturé et bien
malheureusement cet argument de la
saturation est incorrect mais il est
quand même intéressant on va voir
pourquoi et d'ailleurs il ne date pas
d'hier hein il avait même été formulé
pour la première fois en
1901 il faut savoir que dès 1896 le
chimiste suédois vante arenus avait déjà
cherché à quantifier l'impact du taux de
CO2 atmosphérique sur le réchauffement
avant qu'un autre suédois Anders
angstrum ne convainque la communauté
scientifique que ce que disait arenus
était incorrect puisque l'atmosphère
absorbait déjà tout ce qu'elle pouvait
dans les bandes d'absorption du CO2 et
donc que l'effet de ser existait mais
qu'il était saturé sauf qu'arenus et
angstrum il y a plus d'un siècle ne
savaient pas tout ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui sur la physique de
l'atmosphère et du rayonnement alors
voyons ça
ensemble
admettons que l'effet de serre soit
saturé pour le CO2 sa principale bande
d'absorption est autour de 15 microns si
on en croit l'argument tout est absorbé
par l'atmosphère dans cette bande donc
si on observait depuis l'espace le
rayonnement émis par la Terre on devrait
avoir un trou complet rien qui ne passe
mais en fait ça n'est pas vraiment ça
qu'on voit il se trouve qu'on peut avec
des satellites faire des mesures du
rayonnement émis par la Terre notamment
dans l'infrarouge et voici ce qu'on
observe la bande d'absorption à 15
micron est ici et vous voyez
qu'effectivement le spectre est creusé à
cet endroit mais pas du tout jusqu'au
bout il reste du rayonnement dans cette
bande qui s'échappe du sommet de
l'atmosphère comment se fait-il que vu
depuis l'espace avec un satellite la
terre émette du rayonnement à 15 micron
alors qu'on l'a vu juste avant il y a
aucun doute là-dessus l'atmosphère
absorbe complètement dans cette bande et
bien c'est parce que penser que
l'atmosphère ne fait que absorber c'est
une vision erronée un simple trou dans
le spectre c'est ce qu'on aurait à la
limite si l'atmosphère agissait comme un
miroir aux infrarouges qu'elle les
renvoie vers la terre un peu comme ce
que fait une couverture de survie mais
non l'atmosphère absorbe et qui dit
absorption dit émission on l'a dit tout
à l'heure tous les corps rayonnent avec
un spectre qui dépend de leur
température c'est la loi de planque et
elle s'applique au soleil à la surface
de la Terre mais aussi au gaz de
l'atmosphère et la capacité à rayonner
d'un gaz et la même que sa capacité à
absorber ce sont deux processus
symétriques au niveau microscopique plus
un gaz absorbe à une certaine longueur
d'onde plus il va pouvoir émettre à
cette longueur d'onde et donc dans
l'atmosphère les gaz à effet de serre
comme le CO2 non seulement absorbent le
rayonnement infrarouge mais ils vont
également en émettre en rayonner en
suivant aussi la loi de planque donc
pour bien saisir ce qui se passe sur
l'ensemble de l'atmosphère il faut
raisonner par couch successiv prenons
une longueur d'onde donnée disons autour
de 15 minut micro et par exemple les 10
premiers mètres de l'atmosphère à partir
du sol en traversant cette couche une
partie du rayonnement émis par la
surface de la Terre va être absorbé et
l'autre partie va être transmise et
aller vers la couche supérieure mais la
première couche va elle-même émettre du
rayonnement vers le haut et vers le bas
la couche située juste au-dessus voit
donc arriver à la fois le rayonnement
transmis par la précédente auquel
s'ajoute celui émis et on recommence le
raisonnement dans cette deuxième couche
sur ce total qui arrive une partie sera
transmise une partie absorbée et il y
aura de l'émissions en plus et ainsi de
suite et on peut traiter ainsi toutes
les couches de l'atmosphère les unes
après les autres alors heureusement ça
ne dure pas indéfinimen hein puisque
l'air se rarifie quand on monte en
altitude il y a de moins en moins de
molécules de CO2 de moins en moins
d'absorption et de plus en plus de
transmission jusqu'à ce que le
rayonnement s'échappe complètement vers
l'espace et et voyez avec ce
raisonnement que même si l'atmosphère
absorbe à fond une certaine longueur
d'onde dans les couches inférieures elle
émettra quand même dans cette longueur
d'onde à partir des couches supérieures
et donc on verra quand même du
rayonnement à cette longueur d'onde
s'échapper vers l'espace alors pour
l'instant j'explique les phénomènes mais
ce qu'on aimerait c'est pouvoir
quantifier précisément tout ça et pour
ça on peut faire une petite simulation
numérique qui permet de modéliser la
transmission l'absorption et l'émission
dans chaque coup de l'atmosphère et pour
chaque longueur d'onde j'ai fait un
petit code très simplifié en python je
le mettrai sur gitub pour ceux que ça
intéresse bien sûr l'idée n'est pas de
reproduire de façon fidèle les vrais
calculs des chercheurs du domaine mais
de comprendre les principes généraux et
de voir si on retrouve au moins les bons
ordres de grandeur ce qu'on appelle
parfois faire un modèle jouet al voici
comment la simulation fonctionne en
entrée j'ai besoin de connaître les
bandes d'absorption des gaz à effet de
serre il y en a plusieurs he CO2 H2O CH4
et cetera ils ont tous plein de bande
d'absorption qui ont une forme assez
complexe je vais donc faire une très
grosse simplification considérer qu'il
n'y a que le CO2 ne regarder que sa
bande à 15 microns la principale et la
modéliser par une forme approchée on va
aussi avoir besoin d'une description de
l'atmosphère c'est-à-dire d'une courbe
qui donne la pression et la quantité de
molécule en fonction de l'altitude c'est
quelque chose qui est bien connu hein je
vais prendre ce qu'on appelle un profil
hydrostatique et ensuite on y va dans
chaque couche je calque calcule le
coefficient d'absorption qui est donc
aussi le coefficient d'émission il va
bien sûr dépendre de la quantité de CO2
présente dans la couche on considère
qu'il y a un certain pourcentage de CO2
qui est le même partout et comme il y a
de moins en moins d'air en altitude il y
a de moins en moins de molécues de CO2
et je fais tourner mon modèle couche par
couche pour calculer ce qui entre dans
chaque couche ce qui est absorbé
transmis et émis et je le fais pour
chaque longueur d'onde ça se parallélise
bien et on va pouvoir regarder le
résultat et ce résult résultat ce sera
le spectre vu depuis l'espace donct je
vous rappelle qu'il nous permet de
connaître l'énergie totale dont la terre
se débarrasse en regardant l'air sous la
courbe alors il me manque un petit
ingrédient toutefois je vous ai dit que
chaque couche de l'atmosphère émettait
du rayonnement selon la loi de planque
or la loi de planque fait intervenir la
température donc pour ça il nous faut la
température de chaque couche de
l'atmosphère alors commençons par un
modèle simple dans lequel l'atmosphère
est comme la surface de la Terre
uniformément à 15°
je fais tourner mon modèle s'il n'y
avait pas de gaz à effet de serre le
spectre au sommet de l'atmosphère serait
celui-ci he on l'a vu et là quand je
mets les gaz à effet de serre voici ce
que j'ai ah bah ah benah en fait c'est
exactement le même spectre attendez
comment ça se fait l'atmosphère absorbe
à fond dans la bande de 15 microns et il
en ressort pourtant tout autant en haut
de l'atmosphère et bien en fait tout
cela est logique la terre est à 15°gr
elle émet du rayonnement l'atmosphère
l'absorbe en partie et le réémet ensuite
et comme on a supposé que l'atmosphère
était aussi à 15°gr elle le réémet
exactement de la même manière avec une
atmosphère à température constante
identique à celle de la surface il n'y a
aucun impact des gaz à effet de serre
l'émission et l'absorption des
infrarouges sont symétriques le spectre
vu depuis l'espace sera le même qu'à la
surface la seule différence c'est que
dans les bandes d'absorption ce
rayonnement vu de l'espace sera
originaire des couches plus élevées de
atmosphère au lieu d'être en provenance
directe de la surface de la terre ça
veut dire que la grosse différence entre
pas de gaz à effet de serre et présence
de gaz à effet de serre c'est la
provenance du rayonnement qui atteint
l'espace imaginons que je sois capable
d'interroger un à un les photons qui
ressortent au sommet de l'atmosphère
s'il n'y a pas d'effet de serre les
photons me diraientent qu'ils arrivent
tous de la surface mais avec l'effet de
ser ce serait différent hors des bandes
d'absorption les photons seraient aussi
en provenance de la surface mais dans
les bandes d'absorption les photons me
répondraient qu'ils ont été émis par
certaines des couches de l'atmosphère on
peut même quantifier ça plus précisément
et dans la bande du CO2 à 15 microns on
trouverait que la plupart du rayonnement
a été émis entre 10 et 20 km
d'altitude alors maintenant revenons sur
notre hypothèse concernant la
température de l'atmosphère je vous ai
dit que j'avais supposé une atmosphère à
température constante c'est évidemment
pas le cas pour la nôtre alors utilisons
plutôt un vrai profil de température
dans la cou inférieure qu'on appelle la
troposphère la température chute
d'environ 6,5°gr par kilm et à environ
11 km d'altitude on arrive dans une zone
appelée la tropopose où la température
devient essentiellement constante
environ - 55° celus soit autour de 217
Kin j'injecte ce profil de température
dans mon code et je l'utilise pour la
loi de planque et donc le rayonnement de
chacune des couches et là j'observe dans
le spectre vu de l'espace qu'il y a
maintenant un trou autour de la bande
des 15 microns mais un trou qui ne va
pas jusque tout en bas il reste du
rayonnement émis vers l'espace dans
cette plage de longueur d'onde et on
peut comprendre exactement la forme de
ce trou je vous ai dit que dans cette
bande autour de 15 microns les photon
qui atteignaient l'espace provenaient
principalement des altitudes situées
entre 10 et 20 km or on l'a dit cela
correspond à cette zone de l'atmosphère
appelée la tropopose où la température
est essentiellement constante autour de
217 Kelvin
donc les rayonnements qui sont là ont
été émis à la température de 217 Kelvin
et ça se voit d'ailleurs très bien parce
qu'on peut tracer un spectre de planque
à 217 Kelvin et voir que ça les pousse
parfaitement et grâce à ça on comprend
vraiment comment marche l'ffet de C
atmosphérique l'absorption n'élimine pas
les rayonnements infrarouges dont se
débarrasse la terre mais il les fait
parvenir de zones de l'atmosphère plus
froide et donc moins efficace pour
rayonner alors souvenez-vous bien que je
suis sur un modèle jouet ultra simplifié
hein juste le CO2 avec une seule bande
d'absorption mais qualitativement on
comprend bien ce qui se passe le trou
qu'on voit dans le spectre vu de
l'espace n'est pas directement un effet
de l'absorption en soi mais provient
d'un rayonnement réémis depuis des
couches plus froide de l'atmosphère et
donc moins intense et ce qu'on voit est
bien raccord avec les observations
satellites ici c'est bien un petit bout
de spectre de planque à 217 Kelvin
environ et pour les parties que l'on
voit là elles correspondent à du
rayonnement est mis majoritairement dans
la troposphère donc entre la température
de la surface et celle de la
tropopose parfois pour schématiser on va
parler d'altitude d'émission en faisant
comme si tous les rayonnements d'une
certaine longueur d'onde provenaient
d'une altitude spécifique de
l'atmosphère mais c'est une
simplification il faut s'imaginer que
c'est distribué autour d'une sorte
d'altitude moyenne pour chaque longueur
d'onde bien maintenant qu'on a bien
compris comment fonctionne l'effet de
serre atmosphérique on va pouvoir se
poser la question de ce qui se passe si
on continue de rejeter du CO CO2 dans
l'atmosphère la référence qu'on prend
généralement c'est le taux de CO2 à
l'air pré-industriel environ 280 ppm 280
ppm parti par million ça fait 0,028 % de
CO2 si je mets cette valeur dans le
modèle j'obtiens donc cette courbe là en
vert maintenant si je double cette
valeur à 560 ppm avec ma simulation
j'obtiens ça alors les courbes ont l'air
très proches hein mais on voit une
légère différence non pas au centre de
la bande mais sur les côté al
souvenez-vous maintenant hein quand on a
des spectres comme ça l'ensemble de
l'air sous la courbe ça représente la
puissance totale que la terre rayonne et
donc la chaleur dont elle arrive à se
débarrasser si on double le CO2 on passe
d'une courbe à l'autre et donc on empute
légèrement cette capacité de
refroidissement alors oui c'est pas
grand-chose hein c'est juste les petites
surfaces qu'on a de chaque côté et on
peut exprimer cette surface en puissance
dans mon modèle simplifié ça représente
en environ 4,8 W par mè Carr cette
valeur c'est le forçage radiatif associé
à un doublement du CO2 par rapport aux
valeurs pré-industriel en doublant le
CO2 la terre perd 4, W par mè Carr de
capacité de refroidissement et donc son
équilibre thermique est rompu et elle va
devoir se réchauffer pour retrouver
l'équilibre al la valeur que je trouve
avec mon modèle très simplifié a le bon
ordre de grandeur mais ça n'est pas non
plus une valeur super précise hein les
vraies simulations des scientifiques
prennent en compte tous les gaz à effet
de serre toutes les bandes d'absorption
et des profils d'atmosphère plus précis
mais la valeur actuellement retenue pour
le forçage radiatif associée à un
doublement du CO2 c'est 3,7 W par mè²
alors si vous voulez expérimenter plus
précisément avec un modèle plus riche
que le mien vous pouvez utiliser le
modèle mod Tran qui est en accès libre
sur le site de l'université de Chicago
vous pouvez rentrer vos paramètres et
voir les spectres associés le flux
sortant total et estimer les forçages
radiatifs en faisant les différents
entre deux scénarios un truc que vous
verrez c'est que si vous allez vers des
taux de CO2 suffisamment élevés on voit
apparaître un petit pic dans le spectre
en plein centre de la bande à 15 microns
ce pic correspond à des longueurs d'onde
où l'absorption est tellement forte que
l'altitude d'émission est déplacée
au-delà de 20 km dans une zone qui est
la stratosphère où la température
réaugmente quand on monte cela
correspond à une émission plus chaude
que dans la tropopose et donc cela
produit ce petit pic dans le spectre
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs aussi sur les
vraies observations satellites
malheureusement ce pic est bien trop
petit pour compenser le forçage radiatif
qu'on a par ailleurs mais il a au moins
un avantage sur le plan de la
compréhension scientifique puisque
l'émission en plein cœur de la bande a
lieu dans la stratosphère une prédiction
de ce modèle est que si la surface de la
Terre se réchauffe en revanche la
stratosphère doit se refroidir
légèrement l'article scientifique qui a
fait cesel calcul pour la première fois
a été publié très tôt en
1967 notamment par le scientifique
japonais siukuro Manabe qui a reçu le
prix Nobel de physique en 2021 et alors
petit fun fact pour les habitués du RERB
c'est précisément cet article dont on
peut voir les équations reproduites avec
des fautes sur les quais du RER à Gare
du Nord bref ces modèles prédisent
depuis longtemps qu'à cause de
l'augmentation de l'effet de serre la
stratosphère doit se refroidir et c'est
effectivement quelques chose qu'on
observe depuis plusieurs décennies et
qui valide notre compréhension du
mécanisme de l'effet de serre il y a
d'ailleurs eu une publication très
récente sur le sujet qui montre très
bien tout cela en conclusion on voit que
le lien entre concentration en gaz à
effet de serre et forçage radiatif est
plutôt très bien compris et repose sur
des phénomènes physiques qu'on maîtrise
bien sauf que pour avoir des estimations
précises et bien il faut faire un modèle
complet avec tous les gaz et toutes les
bandes pas comme le mien mais sur le
plan fondamental il y a pas trop de
débat bar les estimations d'ailleurs
varient assez peu depuis 30 ans au fur à
mesure qu'on affine un peu plus les
modèles et les mesures des bandes
d'absorption 3 à 4 W par mère carré pour
un doublement du CO2 ça semble être le
tarif al une fois qu'on en est là du
point de vue de la modélisation on a
fait que la moitié du chemin il faut
ensuite pouvoir calculer l'impact de ce
forçage radiatif sur la température à
l'échelle mondiale dans l'atmosphère
dans les océans en fonction des
différents endroits de la planète et des
différents scénarios pour cela on
utilise une autre classe de modèle les
modèles de circulation générale qui se
basent notamment sur les équations de la
mécanique des fluides et qui pour le
coup mobilise des puissances de calcul
bien plus importante mais bon ça ce sera
pour un prochain épisode merci d'avoir
suivi la vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner si ça vous a plu à rejoindre le
serveur discord de science étonnante
pour prolonger la discussion un grand
merci à Jacques trainer et Jean-Louis
dufine deux spécialistes de ces
questions qui ont écrit un très bon
article sur le sujet et qui m'ont mis
sur la voie pour que j'arrive à créer
mon propre petit modèle numérique
abonnez-vous si vous aimez ce contenu et
puis moi je vous dis à très vite pour
une nouvelle vidéo à
[Musique]
bientôt